über bernd schade dass du mir noch nicht
geantwortet hast aber vielleicht mehr
wichtig auch mit meinen mails es ist
alles so aufregend morgen habe ich die
aufnahmeprüfung und eben habe ich auf
dem markt ein sehr nettes mädchen
kennengelernt
lena und ich glaube sie mag mein
mitbewohner kann ich dich geschrieben
klar was gibts was studierst du dich ich
weiß dass gar nicht eingeschrieben nicht
für pädagogik aber das ist nur für meine
eltern damit sie beruhigt sind
eigentlich bin ich hier weil ich an die
kunsthochschule will was studierst du
denn studieren architektur hier an der
fachhochschule fachhochschule
was ist denn das ihr habt so komische
worte wirklich stimmt das ist auch eine
universität aber es ist verschulter da
ist auch ein komisches wort kommt von
schule
naja jedenfalls hat das studium an einer
fachhochschule einen höheren
praxisanteil als das an einer normalen
universität
das ist ganz schön stressig ich mache
meinen bachelor deswegen habe ich auch
so viel zu tun
das sehe ich da lernst ja auch andauernd
aber was ist eigentlich mit mark ist ja
nicht auch student doch aber ich glaube
er weiß selbst nicht mehr wofür
eigentlich eingeschrieben ist wirklich
germanistik anglistik und allgemeine
sprachwissenschaft
soweit ich mich erinnere in bonn aber
ehrlich gesagt jeder nicht mehr die uni
seit monaten fährt er nur noch tagsüber
hin zu hause rum und dass seine freundin
ihn verlassen da kann auch nicht der
einzige grund dafür sein
kennst du die denn zulehner aus der uni
nein ich habe noch gar nicht angefangen
zu studieren
morgen habe ich mein aufnahmegespräch an
der kunsthochschule
du musst mir die daumen drücken liebe
joojoo ich glaube fest an dich du
schaffst das morgen vielleicht schaffe
ich es morgen dich abzuholen
alles liebe ben a